votre ami clémence part en voyage pour
deux semaines durant son absence c'est
vous qui nous lie c'est son chat et
arroser ses plants mais lors d'une de
vos visites vous ici et débouler les
escaliers le choc est violent vous avez
une vilaine fracture au bras droit et
votre cellulaire en a mangé toute une
c'est la catastrophe vos traitements de
physiothérapie et d'ergothérapie se
multiplient et comme vous n'avez pas
d'assurance privée la facture gonfle à
vue d'oeil mais votre voisine clémence
vous rassure son assurance va vous
indemniser puisqu'elle contient de l'eau
en responsabilité civile sauf que
clément ceux dont la clause de
responsabilité civile ne peut pas
s'appliquer puisqu'elle n'a pas été
degli jantes son escalier il sa rampe
étaient conformes et aucun objet
traînait dans les escaliers heureusement
le contrat d'assurance de clémence
contient des garanties complémentaires
qui la couvre pour ce genre d'accident
une partie de vos frais médicaux et deux
roues dommages matériels pourront donc
vous être remboursés le fin mot de
l'histoire votre couverture en
responsabilité civile dont un million de
dollars c'est peut-être impressionnant
si ce n'est pas une assurance accidents